Swindell Rahman over him at hamdulillahi
rabbil alameen salat wa salam o allah
rasool e kareem either early he was
happy huge main
[Arabic recitation]
sharika lahu al la sala he no ash hadu
ajma'in i'm adam
thank you to everybody on the livestream
for joining us today this afternoon and
shall law continuing our
brief
course
comprised of about four sessions with
regards to various superstitions various
false beliefs that would nullify a
person's islam either partially or
completely
right this is what is referred to by the
scholars of islam as co for a kebab
welcome for auto-ship
when a kebab or shere khan asaf
los become the scholars of islam have
divided the types of
association of partners unto Allah they
have divided it into two types and
wherever in the Quran in the Sun now we
find a type of shift mentioned it is
going to fall into one of these two
types some scholars have mentioned it
into three types categorized it the
point is is that the first type is
major shift
what's meant by major major is that it
will completely
nullify a person's Islam meaning that
this person in doing this act will
exit the fold of Islam right this is
called major ship worshipping idols
things that right
the second type is what is referred to
as minor shift now
minor is relative meaning it is
only minor compared to it's more serious
major counterpart major shift but it is
no minor thing in the religion of a loss
of Hanna without it the scholars of
Islam have agreed that minor shift is
more heinous and serious than any major
sin in Islam
minor shift is
anything that has been considered
in the Quran in the Sunna
but does not take a person out of the
fold of his limb such as the app showing
off
somehow bragging about a person's
warship
you know talisman Goodluck charms all of
these things that we were speaking about
in previous sessions these are all types
of minor for the most part while
they can become major ship but for the
most part they are
considered types of minor
now the difference again the key
difference between major and minor shift
is that minor completely takes a
person out of the fold of his net this
person becomes no longer a Muslim
minor ship
a person is considered to have committed
the sin of but is still considered
to be a Muslim which means that this
person has invalidated a portion of his
Aslam not all of his system a portion of
it now when we discuss these issues of
major and minor ship major and minor
Khufu major and minor you know there's
many of them major and minor hypocrisy
all right
when we discuss these things we are not
passing a judgment or a ruling on any
particular person we are speaking about
these things in the abstract at this
point meaning do not take what we say
here and apply it to any individual
right including yourself
what I mean is the ruling of this person
you are not to take these
statements or generalities that we are
discussing in the abstract and then
apply them to
any other person to say this person is
out of the fold of Islam this person is
invalidated a portion of his aslam
because there is a difference between
the
ruling and
the person that does it there is a
difference that the scholars of Islam
have made a distinction
and that is that for
something to be considered the act to be
considered shipped or Co flawed or
what-have-you
this is clear in the Book of Allah and
the son of the prophets a little loan
you asylum however to apply this to a
person there are many conditions right
and there are many what the scholars
refer to as melenik things that will
defer the judgment to where the
judgments will not apply to that person
so
these conditions have to be met and
these things which prevent a person from
falling into that Court category have to
all be absent right so for example let's
take a good example from the sudden of
the prophets on the law on you ascendant
in the abstract let's mention the
narration and then discuss the ruling so
the Prophet sallallahu wasallam
mentioned in sahih al-bukhari and this
is one
this is one
narration of many many narrations
that discuss this issue
the profits all alone he was said lemon
saw he had wada mentioned that a man of
some previous nation
was a person who had acquired much sin
and he had
exceptionally wrong to himself in way of
disobedience to a law and sinfulness and
when he was about to die and he was
essentially drawing his final breaths he
was on his deathbed
he said to his children who were around
him he said when I die
cremate my body
take half of the ashes and throw them
into the sea
and the other half of the ashes and
disperse them into the wind
because if Allah
does resurrect me he will punish me a
punishment that no one
will ever have seen the likes of now
let's take a moment here and look at
this statement that he made
we can see that he is in a
state of immense fear right overwhelming
amounts of anxiety because he is about
to meet a law having incurred all of
this sin in disobedience and
so he commands his children to do
something that if he really believes in
this this is a type of cool so for a
person to believe that if you are
cremated and half of your ashes are
scattered here and half are scattered
there that Allah will not be able to
reassemble you will not be able to
resurrect you by doing so obviously this
is disbelief
right
but what drove him to such belief he is
looking at this point for any any
purpose any anything that he can do
to try to escape the wrath and anger of
a loss of Hannibal without it
what has driven him to this obviously
his belief in a look he believes in
Allah now one of two things either he
was so overwhelmed with anxiety that he
wasn't thinking correctly and so he
said this things to his children or he
was so ignorant of allah subhanaw taala
and so uneducated
that he had little to no
understanding of who allah subhanaw
taala is or knowledge we should say of
who a loss of high notes at it is so the
prophet sallallaahu seldom mentions in
the narration that allah subhanahu
wata'ala then resurrected this man after
he had died and his children had done
this and he asked the man what drove you
to do this and he said fear of meeting
you fear of your punishment and the
prophet sallal oh I do seldom said that
upon this a loss of hano is Allah
forgave him admitted him into paradise
now Allah subhana WA Ta'ala forgave him
forgiveness is
something that is conditional meaning a
person must meet a set of conditions in
the Book of Allah and the Sunnah of the
Prophet SAW alone on even cellular to be
forgiven in the hereafter right and one
of those conditions is that a person be
a Muslim
and so we see that this person is a
Muslim but because of these Malena so we
can say that act or that belief is
Kufa is a belief of this is a belief of
Kufa it is a type of disbelief in Allah
that you do not believe that Allah can
resurrect the dead and this is clear
through the Quran right
so in the abstract that statement that
belief that action is a type of khufu
right but when we apply that ruling to
this person we see that there is now a
difference between the action of coho
and a person who is a calf if someone
who has exited the fold of Islam why
because there are conditions to this a
person can only exit the fold of Islam
when they intentionally no this is this
is wrong this is ship this will take me
out of the fold of Islam and then they
do it
right so there has to be action there
has to be knowledge there has to be
intention there has to be
the mental capacity a person has to be a
sound mind right and when we say of
sound mind they're not drunk they're not
intoxicated they're not inebriated
they're not
overwhelmed with any kind of emotion
that would cloud their judgment or cause
them to misspeak right
we could take another example of this
and the reason we are dwelling on this
is because of its importance
people oftentimes and
many beginning people who are in their
beginning stages of learning about us
then
they have a very hard time
separating between the ruling and the
abstract and the application of this
ruling to a person the application of
this ruling to a person is something
that has such strict
such strict
conditions that have to be met in order
for this person to have this ruling of
having exited the
the fold of Islam that some scholars of
Islam have mentioned it is about as
unlikely to find all of these conditions
being met as it would be to climb a tree
and find a cow had Clement climbed the
tree ahead of you and sitting on top of
the tree this is extremely unlikely
possible I suppose but very highly
improbable
another example of this is
when we have
there is a narration in wahad a.m.
listen him on the authority Venice that
a man the prophet sallallaahu a seldom
said Allah is more
more
pleased
ecstatic with your repentance than any
of you would be if he had lost his
riding animal his camel upon which was
it was where his provisions his water
his sustenance in a huge desert now he's
unable to find his way he has no hope of
reaching civilization and so he finds
the shade of a tree he sits under this
tree and waits for death
become hopeless that he will ever make
it out of this desert alive and then he
looks up and there is his camel had come
back to him with all of his
you know whether it's his maps or his
water as provisions etc and
upon seeing
his camel there in front of him and upon
seeing that he now has his hope restored
of being able to make it out of this
predicament alive he says
out of enthusiasm Aloha and table do you
want another oh Allah you are my servant
and I am your Lord
the prophets all alone on you asylum
said Ozma I mean she didn't thought that
he you know he misspoke because he was
so excited and so relieved now this
statement oh Allah you are my servant
and I am your Lord in the abstract we
say this statement is a statement of
disbelief this is not a statement of
belief
this would take a person out of the fold
of his limb to believe such a thing to
say such a thing however we see that
extreme amounts of joy or extreme
amounts of relief caused him to miss
speak so the person's mind becomes
clouded based on how their emotions
color things for them for this reason in
Sunna and an essay the prophet sallal
own idea was seldom
prohibited that a person judge that a
judge make a judgment while he is angry
right because your anger will
magnify
the negative and mitigates the positive
right so the point is is that when we
discuss major minor major coup
for minor couple etc etc we are not
speaking about any person we are not
speaking about any people we are
speaking about the ruling of these
things in the abstract as opposed as
found in the Quran and in the Sunna
to apply these rulings to a person no
this is something that has many
conditions and can only be done
by someone who is a judge right
in that sense so again we are discussing
these things in the abstract and
we are not
you know applying these rulings to any
person so if you see somebody doing
something you don't want to exclaim that
they are no longer Muslim or something
of this sort because this is exactly the
kind of bigotry and exactly the kind of
ignorance that has caused people
throughout human history
to spill each other's blood to
transgress against one another in the
name of
religion in the name of Islam right
this is not not correct at all this is
not correct at all
and so
another another example of this that we
can discuss is the example of a
person who is not Muslim now when we say
a person to enter paradise must be
Muslim this is the condition this is the
prerequisite of entering paradise
so does that mean that every single
individual that
dies upon
not being Muslim will enter the Hellfire
the answer is in the abstract yes but
applying that abstract ruling to people
then the answer may be no because there
may be a number of things that were not
met conditions that were not met right
the person never heard of his left the
person heard of Islam in an extremely
distorted manner which caused the person
to discredit it right the person is
does not have the mental capacity to
embrace a snail or to understand it or
to take it seriously these are what are
called in law mitigating factors right
and these mitigating factors of our
serious
with a loss of Hanna what either so for
this reason it but not best will be
Allah why Allah says it is not for any
individual
to
claim that any other person is in
paradise or in hellfire the only way we
know if somebody is in paradise or in
the Hellfire is if a loss of Hannah
Matata tells us that or if the prophets
all along on you ascendant tells us that
otherwise we have no way of knowing that
we have no way of knowing if we
ourselves I cannot tell you myself with
any certainty where I will be let alone
to tell you where anyone else will be
and this narration is in Asahi aware
one of the wives of one of the
companions who passed away she had said
that this person is to Paradise for sure
and the prophet sallallahu alayhi wa
seldom asked her how do you know this
he said I spy the meaning of the
narration I swear by Allah I am The
Messenger of Allah and I don't even know
what will be done with me now this
obviously is to drive home the fact and
to articulate emphatically
just how
just how much of our affairs is in the
hands of Allah and to the judgments of a
loss of Hanna Toyota we are in a
position of being judged not in a
position of judging so I want to mention
that very importantly it's an important
introduction to these topics when we
discuss topics of Islam and when we
discuss topics of belief in disbelief
and entering the fold of Islam and
exiting the fold of Islam and all these
things we are not speaking about any
individual we are speaking about in the
abstract
these things this is the ruling of a
loss of Hanna Matata in this thing and
so the only person you can control and
the only person you should apply this to
is yourself right the only person you
should apply this to you should teach
this to others you should teach your
families these things right
judgement is reserved for allah subhanho
wa taala allah subhanho wa taala says in
no uncertain terms in the quran in in
hook Mullally left that judgment is
reserved only for a loss of Hanna with
right and so we judge
based on the judgment to whole law
that's it that's all the judge does a
judge in Islamic law judges only by thee
by the judgment of Allah or what he
presumes is the judgment of Allah to the
best of his abilities
likewise
we view the world in
the way that we are told by a loss of
Han Matata and the prophets all along I
knew a senator regardless of how we feel
this is right and this is wrong and
those lines are drawn in the sand right
it is not for any person to come and
categorize something as right or wrong
without authority from Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala well subhana Allah said well Atta
who knew limit oclc not to communicate
deeper the higher animal had a Haram
bleach after ala llahi caddy he said and
do not say to those things which your
tongues described this is Hallel this is
lawful and this is unlawful
which in
tale will be a type of fabrication of
lie against a law and falsehood unless
Allah Subhan Allah to Allah determine
something as right or wrong we have no
right to do that right
likewise a scholar a scholar does not
bring us new rulings since this is not
what a scholar does right this is not
you know some religions pundits or
or
priests or these these types of people
rabbis they can judge for people that
this is right and this is wrong and this
is appropriate and this is inappropriate
that is not for anybody except for Allah
a scholars position in Islam is merely
to carry on the legacy of the Prophet
SAW alone yourself that's it right to
carry on the legacy to propagate the
legacy to teach the legacy
right to the best of his ability or her
ability
today we want to speak about a set a set
which is often translated to magic
however it has a much more broad meaning
in the religion of Islam and the
in the legislation of Islam while sif
magic is
that's its translation it it entails and
incorporates many other things into it
right that traditionally we may not
consider to be a type of magic in our
minds but
the principle of Islam is that no two
things which are similar are separated
in a laws judgment and no two things
which are different dissimilar are
joined together in a laws judgment so
kind of with that so when we see that
these things fall into the generality of
magic we see that these things either
are derived for a magic derived from the
worship of other than a law or these
things have a portion of that type of
belief that go along with it
magic
in its
essential form which it is mentioned in
the Quran throughout the Quran what is
meant by magic is
a very tight a very specific type of
magic and that is that an individual
do things for different Shelton what we
call in English demons
the Sheltie and the bad of the jinn that
a person does things to appease them in
way of worship in order that they may
help this person to perform things and
feats which seem to be
mysterious and unbelievable this is what
is meant by magic so when Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala says in Surat
al-baqarah in the sixteenth page he
mentions soup Anna without inverse of
that this
magic is a type of Kufa it is a type of
disbelief right it is a type of
disbelief
what it what a loss of Panama tada is
speaking about is a very specific type
of magic and he mentions it even the the
origin of this type of magic and he
mentions the city of Babylon in this
verse
and that is worship of
celestial bodies
worship of nature
worship of idols worship of different
demons right or different Jim
in order to gain some kind of spiritual
edge or in order to gain the aid of
these creatures this is cool right
the scholars of Islam differ on whether
merely learning it is this belief or its
application only is disbelief right and
the point here is that the Prophet SAW
Allah Miley was seldom used
to make dua and say Allah mania Ljubica
metalman layin fat o Allah I seek refuge
in you lest I learn any knowledge which
has no which is of no consequence which
is of no benefit right why is this the
prophets all alone on you asylum seeking
refuge in Allah from
knowledge which has no benefit no
benefit to your livelihood in this world
no benefit to your salvation in the next
world
because the human being
will act upon knowledge any knowledge
that you gain will incorporate itself
into your beliefs which will translate
into speech and action right and
decisions any knowledge that you have
any knowledge that you incorporate into
your heart so any knowledge that comes
into your heart and
you take it in and it is
unbeneficial
let alone if it is something negative or
bad or terrible these things will
translate into your actions and beliefs
they will at least cloud
your mind from seeing the truth as true
and seeing false or this false right
what is meant by
unbeneficial knowledge knowledge of
things that have no consequence in this
life where they Hereafter right what is
meant by
negative knowledge knowledge of that
which is prohibited in Islam right
knowledge of bartending for example
knowledge of how to make wine how to
make alcohol knowledge of drugs how to
cook correct any any of these things
which are prohibited in Islam right
this type of knowledge is prohibited to
learn unless there is some necessary
purpose for it which applies to
less than 1% of the Muslim world right
so for example for a Muslim scholar to
learn about a particular
thing in order to pass a ruling on it or
in order to
decipher what is correct or incorrect or
in order to they must learn about it to
an extent that is different right this
is knowledge that becomes consequential
not in itself but because of what it
leads to or because of what is based
upon that knowledge or knowing it
the profits all alone he was seldom
warned us from civet he warned us from
magic and all of its types and we will
speak about the types of said and show
law
and the very famous narration of Evy
Loyola which is collected by both
millennium with them that The Messenger
of Allah Salih law and he was seldom
said that any boo acetylene will be a
clutch
he said stay clear and refrain and stay
far from the seven
essentially seven deadly sins or seven
most destructive sins
they said o Messenger of Allah and what
are they those seven sins now if you
notice loss of panowitz our dimensions
in sort of the ledger regarding the
[Arabic recitation]
in men whom Jews one mocks ooh he says
so panel to Anna
that the Hellfire has seven gates for
each gate and allotted portion of people
who are are appropriate for that gate
and so we have here a correlation seven
most deadly sins and these could be the
overarching
themes of each of those gates of the
Hellfire or they could be others the the
prophets all alone I knew a cinema was
asked what are they and he said a
who bila worship of other than Allah as
said
magic well cut to learn FZ Letty Haram
[Arabic recitation]
Allah bellhop and
the murder
spilling blood
the murder of
an individual without right to do so
spilling of blood taking a life
right he says well Arriba
Ussery what is referred to as interest
right to consume interest take interest
welcome a Thalia team and
taking
unrightfully of the wealth of an orphan
what doe a glioma Zeff and
fleeing from battle
welcome a son at a La Follette and want
me net and
wrongfully slandering and accusing of
indecency
those chaste
believing women or not of that
are not of that act of indecency and
so we see that the second thing
mentioned after a will be left
after associating partners on to allah
subhanahu wata'ala is a
set magic right now what is what is
the meaning of magic what is magic let's
discuss because we said magic has a
meaning in our minds and in our culture
right but in the legislation of Islam it
there is it is it is a kind of unwritten
umbrella that
incorporates many other acts beliefs and
individuals right it's not just a person
who casts a spell or a person that
warships shall clean there are other
types of people and types of things
which fall into this general category
we have a narration which was collected
by Imam Ahmed even-handed Rahim a hello
to Anna
that the Prophet sallallahu aleyhi wa
salem
was narrated to have said on the
authority of copiously will be a lot
Lionel
he said in Elia Fattah
toca well clear autumn in Egypt II
he said that these three things are a
type of magic Zubat in the quran what's
meant by gypped is magic right and
why magic is referred to as gypped in
the quran the scholars of islam have
mentioned with regards to the linguistic
etymology of this word and jibbety which
is mentioned in sort of the micelle
that al-jabat in the original in its
original form or meaning refers to
failure
EG 'but really he who had fashioned that
is failure right
and so allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
describes magic with a word that is
synonymous to sit but articulates an
additional portion of meaning which is
failure and that is as Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala said well are you free Jose hello
hi through Atta that the magician will
never be successful no matter what route
he takes right it will always fail
because it is based on the worship of
other than a loss of hand of what
happened
so a loss of the prophet sallallaahu I
know you ascend them says that these
three things are part of Egypt en el
área fetta la boca what the errata mean
LGBT right let's let's unpack that let's
break that down in the Nava what is
alpha and alpha is what we've spoken
about before and that is a type of
ominous
thing it's it's a type of looking and
searching for negative omens this is
called an AFO right you feel so he is
edge of a plate and we mentioned this
that you know the Arabs had certain
beliefs with regards to certain birds
certain animals and their actions right
certain animals and their actions so if
they would see a particular type of bird
they would take this to be ominous or
take this to be a good omen
right
what book a thug is essentially drawing
lines in the sand what does that mean
they would
have you for instance there are certain
fortune tellers what we call fortune
tellers psychics write that what they'll
do is
and info a scene where I'm from what
they do is they have you drink a cup of
coffee and then after you drink the cup
of coffee they'll take the coffee and
put out the grounds of the coffee
onto a table or look at it or in your
poem whatever it is right
because every coffee has the grounds in
it that settle at the bottom and then
they will essentially look into that cup
or look into that coffee you're looking
to those grounds and
claim to see
your future see your
vocation whatever it is right this is
called a book
we have other types of which is
what we we call an America palm reading
they'll look at your poem and they'll
say this is the low sign and this is the
diss and this is that right what is the
connection to the
folds of skin in my palm to
my
my direction in life there is no
connection this is merely a genetic
thing and depending on what kind of work
I do that's it right so
these are types of a book in
the time of the Prophet SAW alone I need
to settle them they would draw things in
the sand and look at them right we have
other things that we do there are
certain types of
there are certain types of soothsayers
fortune-teller psychics in the Western
world
where they will actually give a person
an enema and then look into you know the
whatever has come out very disgusting
but this is something that is done right
anything of this sort is a type of is a
type of bug
right and this is prohibited in Islam it
is a type of set it is a type of magic
it falls into the general inclusivity
the general umbrella of
magic according to the
Book of Allah and the Sunnah of the
Prophet SAW Allah why they it was said
them and according to that definition
there's other things that are done that
followed the same path
people will you know
there is something that is kind of
controversial for example look at a
particular
what we call tarot cards right
tarot cards is kind of cards with you
know the tower and the steeple and all
these different things and you draw
cards and there's a way to do it and
then they can foresee your omens in New
York or in your future with this thing
right tarot cards this is can be
considered the type of a type of bulk
this can also be considered a type of a
type of
selim selim right now sediment right for
this we're talking about Zelan as elem
or an islam in the time of the prophet
sallallahu wasallam is a type of
superstition that they used to try to
make a decision we have its equivalent
in
in America which we'll discuss and that
is that as Lomb
would be basically three sticks or three
arrows
one of the arrows has yes one of the
arrows has no one of the arrows says you
know draw again or one of the arrows
says do it the other says don't do it
the other says the third says drug in
and they'll put these into a bag right
and then you draw one and you draw one
with a particular thing in mind should I
marry this person should I go on this
journey should I go to this battle
whatever it is a decision that you are
trying to make and you draw this and you
will then predict this we have something
similar to this the magic a ball
which is sold as a novelty item right
I'm not sure how prevalent it is now but
in the 90s when I was a kid it was you
know all over the place it's a novelty
item it's an eight ball the pool
you play pool the eight ball and
then it's got a little window liquid and
and you shake it up and ask a question
and an answer floats to the top right
this is what is referred to as SLM in
the little pond right and allah subhanho
wa tada mentions that an Islam is
a
filth a stain essentially on the hearts
of humanity it is a filth from the
handiwork of a shave bun
and we are commanded to abstain from it
and it is incorporated along with
slaughtering for idols
gambling alcohol etc it is mentioned
alongside these these terrible things
this is called a less lemon right the
tarot cards fall into that
let's say a person says okay should I do
this or should not and then you you know
take up a
let's say a paper make a paper ball and
shoot it into a wastebasket and if if it
if it gets in the basket it's yes and if
it misses the basket it's no this is a
type of ship right this is a type of as
LEM and the legislation of a loss of
hanim without is prohibited now again
back to our principle that Allah
mentions to us and that is just because
people don't make a big deal out of it
or just because magic 8-ball is found in
the toy aisle as opposed to you know in
the toy aisle at Walmart as opposed to
some more serious place just because it
is a novelty thing or just because it is
widespread doesn't mean that it is a
light to matter it doesn't mean that it
is of little consequence it can be very
serious then loss of kind of it's out I
said what I said when at will hey you
know what we are in the law I mean you
all may consider this you all consider
this to be lights matter something of
little significance yet with a law it is
of extreme gravity
right so
these these things are a type of a
type of talk right other types of
thought would be
astrology which will speak about next
week in shell law
the
horoscopes
another type of the generality of a
thought of would be
something that is kind of funny and kind
of quirky and people are going to but
for example
Chinese fortune cookies right
for you to open the fortune cookie into
looking you know and it's always very
vague and if you actually look to where
people get these
get these statements that are in the
fortune cookie you will be in home it's
it's very funny for example most
fortune cookies in America or a huge
portion of fortune cookie
are made in a factory in Brooklyn New
York
how do they come up with what to put in
these fortune cookies well they have a a
group of you know a a panel
and they will all propose certain
statements to put in the fortune cookie
and there will vote on whether this is
good or not and you you have to
understand it's always very vague very
general you know you will meet someone
who will be of great consequence to you
today or will help you very much that
could be anybody it could be the bus
driver right
it is general enough to apply
be applied applicable to everyone and a
lot of people and this very materialist
society will always
kind of
excuse themselves publicly and say oh
it's just fun alright but
if this was just fun it wouldn't be
taken so seriously there are many other
things which people do which are
supposed to be of good omen or bad omen
something the wishbone and Turkey
you know in turkey dinners there's this
bone that's called the wishbone and
allegedly you hold one side and the
other holds another side and and
you guys separated and break it and
whoever gets the bigger portion makes a
wish that will come true this is all the
type of and
there's another thing where people take
a straw wrapper and make a knot and then
pull it apart if it comes to the right
it's yes and if it comes to the left
it's no right or or it's good or
somebody is speaking well about you or
whatever it is this is all the type of
bubble type of sick a type of 10 gene
which we will get into more detail about
in the
coming lecture in Chihuahua Tejada the
profits all alone on you asylum mentions
the third and final thing which is a
Lyra a theatre are the omens which we've
been discussing and we had an entire
lecture about
the week before
right he says that in Java
which is regards to birds and so forth
what bulk which are the lines and the
sand that the arabs used to draw what
Liara which are the op ominous you know
taking bad omens this is all minute of
Jupiter this is all considered part of a
divot which is
superstition and this is all part of
linguistically all part of failure right
a loss of Hana what's a dimensions that
won this praise of a certain people is
you'll be known a village ibbity Love
Boat that they believe in energy beauty
so mere belief in these things is
sufficient to stain an individual's
heart and to tarnish a person's Islam
and to invalidate a portion of an
individual's aslim let alone to actually
do these things we will conclude there
and we will continue next week in sha
[Arabic recitation]
sallim ala nabina muhammad by the early
he was happy